allo salut thomas c'est yann galut va
changer c'est incroyable joie non merci
allez c'est bon des courses applaudir un
vieux un vieux t'as les poils le coup
tout blanc a dévoilé la regarde question
pour un champion à séville ça va je t'ai
vu tu rends tu as complètement buggé
condamné à vivre éternellement tour
d'adolescence
jours sur place et importées alors c'est
quoi ton tour de hausse
une fête comme à l'époque avec tous nos
potes comme avant on commence par qui
honore et nous fournissons le mec le
plus cool mec ou surtout pleine montagne
pour le premier semestre il a failli
corner quand même nom gp qu'il est
meilleur mais damas a dit quand on était
vraiment un gamin quoi y'a plus mad max
c'est clair salut saillen carbet qu'elle
ne savait pas où vit votre fille
terminal lycée montaigne
à mon avis vous ne voulez pas venir
c'est le plus c'est vraiment génial ça
faudra te revoir
moi je crois qu'on n'oublie rien ça
reste quelque part
râler ya ça me fait plaisir de vous voir
quand on était gamins vous croyez qu'on
était tellement loin de la mort qui
prend au paradis en faire tout ça tu
crois pas toi nirvana kurt cobain tu
crois ça tu crois quoi continuer à se
voir on espère que de maple
je propose qu'on refile attendent tout à
l'heure on attend un peu plus calme
ouais parce que là on va savoir